Russian forces appear closer to taking
control of severo donesk a key City in
Ukraine's Eastern donbus region the
regional Governor there says the last
route out of the city has been destroyed
making it impossible to organize
humanitarian Aid or organize evacuations
of the civilian population hundreds of
Ukrainian Fighters and civilians are
Sheltering in a chemical plant there as
Russian missiles still pound the city
that's become the latest epicenter of
the war
firing back Ukrainian Defense Forces say
this aerial footage shows the
destruction of three Russian Grand
rocket launchers
which they believe were used to shell
the embattled city of severo Donetsk and
surrounding areas
Street battles are raging in the eastern
city the governor of the region says it
is mostly under Russian control much of
severo Donetsk has been destroyed
authorities believe some 500 civilians
including children are Sheltering at the
vast adzot chemical plant
Ukraine has accused Russia of shelling
the works and sparking a fire
russian-backed separatists say they're
holding back from the plant to avoid an
environmental catastrophe
images that remind ukrainians of The
Siege in mariopol steelworks just weeks
ago
in Kiev the defense Ministry described
the difficulty of the current situation
in the east
the second phase of the full-scale
invasion of Russia continues the enemy
continues to outnumber Us in equipment
and artillery the Ukrainian Defense
Forces are actively fighting and
inflicting High losses on the enemy
the Russian Ministry of Defense released
footage claiming to show their troops
opening fire on Ukrainian militants
their spokesperson said they had hit
important targets
in the donets People's Republic High
Precision air launched missiles
destroyed a large number of weapons and
military equipment delivered to the
Ukrainian nationalists including weapons
from the U.S and European countries
an end to the constant shelling and
exchange of fire rages on with no end in
sight and all bridges out of the city
cut
[Music]
let's get the latest now from DW
correspondent Roman gunterenko who's in
the Ukrainian Capital Kiev Roman very
good to see you let's start with that
situation we just heard about in severo
donesque and the azote chemical plant in
that City what is the latest you can
tell us about the situation for
Ukrainian troops and civilians that may
be there
well there is not much information new
information that we are getting
um the main news of the day is probably
that the third Bridge has been blown so
there are no Bridges now connecting to
that city of severodonesque which makes
the situation of Ukrainian forces and
civilians even worse so we know that
hundreds of civilians are hiding in that
chemical plant azot which is the
Ukrainian bird for nitrogen and it's
it's dangerous to be there in normal
times it's a big it's a huge chemical
plant I've seen it and of course it was
not working in in recently but still
there are shortages of chemicals there
it's very dangerous and environmental
catastrophe catastrophe is possible and
we do not know how much food and how
much water those civilians hiding there
still have another information piece of
information that we have and which is
worrying is that the bunkers at that
chemical plant are not that that good as
in mariopol in azov style which was
which was 5 fighting off Russian army
for for weeks or months even so we don't
know how much they can last and that's
why Ukrainian side is negotiating with
the Russian army about the possibility
of those civilians to get out and I
think it's a matter of days and when
they will have to leave that plant
now let's move to elsewhere in the
country Russian forces are claiming that
they've hit Ukrainian arms Depots do you
know anything more about what impact
that's having on the ukrainian's Army
ability to fight
well we can only guess such attacks are
always
um the the aftermath of such attacks are
strictly confidential so Ukrainian Army
is no disclosing any information what we
we know we know that Russia is trying to
hit such targets and um sometimes
Ukraine says there was no military at
that point sometimes there is just no
information like in this case so we can
assume that maybe some some Western
weapons were hit we don't know but um
what we do do know that um even if some
Western weapons in Ukraine are destroyed
they're desperately needed on the front
so um Ukraine is um desperately asking
to send more weapons because as we see
in the east in in this fighting in the
city of severodonesque and the
neighboring City Lisa chansk every
single Canon matters
let's pick up on that thread because the
president of Ukraine zielinski he is
asking for more and faster weapon
deliveries from NATO countries it's uh
unclear just how many of those weapons
are coming
can ukrainians continue fighting without
that and and how do they feel about the
support they're getting from the West
well there is no there are no polls to
that so we can only rely on the
information we get from the governmental
sources or talking to people here in
Kiev in the capital and the the mood is
rather divided I would say basically
most people say yes we are very grateful
for the West for the support for the
military support and but but then when
you talk about special countries the
mood is different so when we talk about
countries like the United States or the
United Kingdom which supported Ukraine
with weapons before uh the war broke out
in in late February so most people are
very grateful and I think that was a
um a very special situation for Ukraine
but when we talk about countries like
Germany which hesitated a lot we hear a
lot of criticism and I wonder when Ken
Chancellor Schultz is going to visit
Kiev this mood will change
from in gunturanko with the latest there
in Kiev thank you very much
wherever possible people keep fleeing
from active battle zones from the
Russian invasion of Ukraine now one of
those areas is the front line of bakmut
which is just south of severe Donuts
that we've just spoken about that City
too has been hit by shelling and much of
its infrastructure has been destroyed
but for now it's still possible for
people to get out
and for more on exactly that effort we
are joined by salaam al-din he's the
founder of Team Humanity the an
international non-profit based in
Denmark his organization helps people
get to safety and he is joining us now
from Ukraine salaam welcome to the show
and thank you for joining us
um you have transported people from this
area
which is quite far to the east where
there's been heavy fighting can you tell
us more about the situation there
yeah it's very hard the situation is
really hard right now
um because the civilians can't get out
and the only way to get them out is
having armored trucks going and quickly
getting them out from the basements from
wherever they are
um and the mostly people actually not
from Bahamut is actually from sever
Donetsk and The Villages around it
so it's really hard to get them out
while they would love let's say the
military when they bring it to us uh
then we need to get them into the buses
and drive them immediately away because
they're bombing also bahut yesterday
we're sitting uh and waiting for um for
the evacuation and then
200 meters away from us you could hear
the bomb like hit somewhere so it's the
situation is really tense right now
really thin
and going off of that there have been so
many efforts to get civilians out of
various places throughout the course of
this war many of these convoys have
failed many of these humanitarian
corridors have failed how are you able
to get in and out of these dangerous
areas
you know we were driving inside and we
were driving from bahmoud to go to sever
Donetsk and then we got stopped by a
checkpoint not so far away like maybe
seven kilometers away from seven to
eight kilometers they said if you go
this way he will not come back uh it
seems like Russians are hiding
themselves in the bushes in the houses
that is not and then when the cars
passed they just shoot after them this
is how it seemed like this is the
soldiers what they told us and then we
are standing next to this checkpoint and
when you see like like like yesterday
where there was a military ambulance
that just passed us and you should like
it was I was almost threwing out because
it was the smell of dead people in that
ambulance you could smell it the window
was open and it just passed us and you
could smell the dead people in it so
it's really like crazy right now and the
most
um the most hard thing is to get the
civilians out and we try to do our best
but to do that we need armored trucks
and we have like two buses small buses
that can get in quick and out again so
um it's really really hard to get
civilians and there is a lot of children
a lot of women we took we had them in
the bus we drove them away they were all
traumatized you could see the children
are traumatized you could see
everybody's trying advertised and also
injured
so it's really really hard right now
you seem really to be on your own there
can you tell us more about what's behind
your operation who's who's able to fund
you to be able to do the work that
you're doing
the people who's funding us is the
people who trust us and believe in our
work uh we've been doing a different
evacuation we're also in Afghanistan
last year evacuating so it's actually
organizations uh non-profit
organizations and mostly civilian people
good people around there that is from
all over the world but sending donations
so we could do the evacuation right now
we were asking for getting an armored
truck so we could get inside where we
know we're going to be shot at we know
we're going to be bonded but our armored
truck can get in quick get the people
out get them to the safety and then
drive them out from that place because
Muhammad is not is not a safe from a
tour still not safe
none of these places are safe because we
were sitting and then the bomb like hit
200 minutes away from us and the people
were standing around it was just normal
you could see their eyes was just
they're traumatized they've been hearing
this bombings like for a very long time
so it's like just a normal thing for
them Salam Al Deen from Team Humanity
International there in Ukraine
thank you very much for taking this time
in a very difficult situation
thank you